[Musique]
m
bonjour et bienvenue sur le plateau de
parlement hebdo une émission spéciale
consacrée à la campagne pour la
présidentielle avec michel annese
bonjour katia bonjour à tous notre
invité cette semaine et frédéric dabi
vous êtes le directeur général adjoint
de l'ifop lassitude tournage avec vous
on va décortiquer analyser toute cette
campagne
toute cette semaine d'entre deux tours
notamment oui on va commencer si vous
voulez bien par la carte de france qui
s'est dessinée à l'issue du premier tour
et qui donne le signe d'une nouvelle
donne politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
frédéric dabi je vous propose de revoir
cette carte de france qui a été très
commentée à la fois en france mais aussi
ailleurs qui marque une fracture nette
entre eux là le vote des villes et le
vol des campagnes de votre des villes
plutôt en faveur d' emmanuel macron
celui des campagnes du taux pour marine
le pen et avec on le voit beaucoup de
forces nouvelles
est ce que le 7 mai frédéric dabi c'est
cette carte là qui va exister à nouveau
oui cette carte est tout à fait
symbolique vous avez raison katia c'est
là c'est la carte de la décomposition du
champ politique de l'affaiblissement
historique du parti socialiste de la
droite qui recule très fortement sauf
dans les bastions du sud est et dans les
grandes zones emmanuel monnet sur tout
ce qui frappe c'est que cette carte
ressemble beaucoup à celle observée le
29 mai 2005
la france dit oui la fin sinon la france
du non qui vote le pen et 1° - jean-luc
mélenchon dans le quart nord-est et 2 et
le quart sud-est et la france de la
façade ouest plus protégés sans doute se
vivent plus comme gagnants de la
mondialisation qui a plutôt choisi et
mâcon mais c'est vrai ce qui est
intéressant dans cette élection
présidentielle au delà de la carte c'est
que les quatre premières forces et
quatre premiers candidats se tiennent en
4 5 points
c'est pas de france qui se font face à
face comme on l'a souvent dans une
élection présidentielle c'était le cas
en 2012
en 2007 ces quatre forces à peu près
équivalente qui signent capable de
france qui s'opposent oui c'est une
entendu
ce nadal et comme on a beaucoup entendu
cela je partage l'idée d'aider de francs
sur la france du oui et la france du non
c'est vrai que la france des grandes
villes qui a voté très peu pour marine
le pen marine le pen fait 4 99% à paris
elle fait très peu dans les grandes
villes
elle surperforme dans les communes
rurales et dans ce périlleux romain qui
se sent des classes est délaissé
abandonné - etats-unis flamand a visité
ce pays
il est l'acteur de 30 alors il faut être
prudent il ya de ça trump
n'oublions pas qu'à l'échelle nationale
il est quand même américaine il est
devancé de 3 millions de voix par
hillary clinton s'est plus de sonder et
à spécifique qu'il a fait la différence
alors quand on est amis on va
s'intéresser à cette semaine d'entre
deux tours et ce duel à distance avec
certainement ce qui restera une image de
cette semaine ce duel à distance à
amiens devant l'usiné
whirlpool marine le pen est arrivée par
surprise à l'endroit où emmanuel macron
devait finalement de tenir un rendez
vous et un meeting je propose de revoir
toute cette séquence avec valérie
brochard et mario châtelain
toute la presse a été conviée à la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie
damien poursuivre le candidat dans
marche à la rencontre des responsables
syndicaux de l'usiné où ils coulent une
heure après leur entretien à huis clos
emmanuel macron reste confiant croyant
au dialogue social alors esprit de
responsabilité je veux travailler avec
eux c'est ce que mon déplacement
aujourd'hui manifestent mais surprise
au même moment à quelques kilomètres de
là marine le pen réalise quelques selphy
avec les ouvriers devant l'usiné en
grève
je suis ici à ma place exactement là où
je dois être au milieu des salariés
devient poule au milieu de ses salariés
résistent à cette mondialisation sauvage
à ce modèle économique est honteux
une visite qui touche certains grévistes
très très contente
déjà de sa venue surprise et elle au
moins elle s'est déplacée alors que
monsieur maquereau en étant sur place
n'a pas souhaité nous rencontrer sur le
site mais a préféré faire venir des
délégations pour le rencontrer la
chambre des commerces prévenu par son
service de communication emmanuel macron
bousculent alors son agenda et décide de
se rendre lui aussi sur le site
l'accueil n'est pas franchement
chaleureux un dialogue difficile
s'installe car la régulation galles pc
et à la retraite plus cités je me
battrai pour qu'elle se fasse
et quand je vous parle de formation
c'est pas du moment là je sais ce que
c'est la condition pour trouver des
corps à ce que vous avez à faire
pas dupe les salariés ont eu
l'impression d'être victime d'un double
buzz médiatique
c'est quand même dommage que on est
obligé d'attendre qu'à cinéma va même
limite c'est même un cirque
il a fallu que marine le pen déboule
sans première personne pour que monsieur
matheron des vignes ouvert peut-être
même du cir la marque saisine sera pas
sauvée et d'usinés perdu du jus et perdu
donc on sait que dans un an et de 1
donc là on se bat pendant du ca il y
aura pas de solution n'aura pas de
repreneur il y en aura pas whirpool ou
le symbole de la lutte pour récupérer le
vote ouvrier en france les candidats
repartent mais les pneus brûlent
toujours emmanuel macron l'a promis il
reviendra sur place pour rendre des
comptes
est ce que vous estimez que ce qu'on a
connu cette semaine devant l'usiné poule
ça marquera peut-être à tournon cette
campagne ou en tout cas symbole de cette
campagne
oui c'est un c'est un acte fort mais ça
me rappelle florence pendant la campagne
présidentielle et florange au début du
quinquennat de françois hollande qui a
été voilà le moment de la rupture entre
françois hollande et les classes
cuillère c'est vrai que marine le pen a
fait un acte de communication fort de
coller à emmanuel macron de donner une
image peuple élite dans un sens c'est à
dire qu'elle est allée voir les ouvriers
quand même à compter avec la chambre
d'industrie et du commerce et des
représentations des représentants
syndicaux et macro lui a peut-être bien
répondu en venant lui-même sur le
terrain il a montré de vue il a montré
du cran alors ce n'est peut-être
s'éteint c'est un symbole
est ce que c'est un tournant dans la
campagne on va le voir mais ça installe
et edward emmanuel macron oui c'est vrai
que ça a tourné la page voilà vraiment
de la retourne vers ses scènes
parisiennes
je pense que la rotonde était moins
signifiant auprès des français que son
discours de 1er tour on a le sentiment
qu'il avait déjà gagné il y avait pas
cette
pacte de dramatisation qu'on avait vu du
côté de jacques chirac par exemple en
2002 là il est allé au contact il allait
au peuple si je si je puis dire c'est un
duel extrêmement attendu et qui a gagné
ce duel est ce que marine le pen on peut
dire au bout de cette séquence qu'elle a
déjà gagné la bataille de l'image
alors ce qui compte c'est gagner la
bataille électorale et sortir vainqueur
du 7 mai l'accord au regard des enquêtes
de l'ifop le rolling ifop fiducial
il ya toujours une avance très net
pourrait belle macro et contrairement à
la campagne présidentielle précédente où
jour après jour et mai nicolas sarkozy
avait grignoté son retard sur françois
hollande pour passer de 56 % début de
campagne à 52% là c'est plutôt stable
c'est un rapport de force de 60 40 60 et
demi trente neuf et demi alors c'est
c'est très fort pour le front national
si on compare au seul référent que nous
avons jean marie le pen en 2002 il avait
fait dix huit et demi pour cent
là on est sur un score deux fois plus
élevée et puis il ya une marine le pen
qui est devancé dans tous les segments
de population par imen akroud sauf
justement les ouvriers et un mot quand
même sur ce qui risque d'être encore une
fois remarqué lors du set mais c'est
l'abstention qui peut battre un record
oui vous avez raison c'est l'indicateur
majeur c'est un indicateur principal à
suivre qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
élection présidentielle de deuxième tour
c'est traditionnellement une élection on
vote plus voir beaucoup plus par exemple
en 2002 qu'au premier tour
la lundi 14 d'absence ont dû rowling est
passé depuis dimanche de 26 à 29 % 7
points de plus que la participation que
plutôt l'abstention enregistrée le 23
avril dernier
il ya un cas historiques que l'on peut
par à la logique mute en étant prudent
rattaché à ce phénomène c'est la
présidentielle de 1969 où le candidat
communiste éliminé peut être pré
mélenchoniens si je puis dire
jacques duclos avait renvoyé dos à dos
alain bauer le centriste georges
pompidou le goal is comme blanc bonnet
et bonnet bonnet blanc et entre le
premier tour et le deuxième tour il y
avait une neuf à dix points de plus
d'abstention c'est peut-être le schéma
peut être le chemin que les électeurs
vont suivre ou ne pas suivre le 7 mai
prochain et on verra tout à l'heure en
analysant qui savent ce qui s'abstient
le plus on va écouter
marine le pen qui était en meeting
6 évidemment elle critique emmanuel
macron débat juste après avec notre
correspondant qui est sur place encore à
nice ce n'est plus une nation mais il
société multiculturelle éclaté ce n'est
plus la république française notre
démocratie est un régime oligarchique où
dominent une caf au service des
puissances d'argent
une société où la seule loi est la loi
du plus fort dans le monde globalisé
auquel aspire monsieur macron et qu'il
nous présente comme heureux tout se vend
et tout s'achète
on va rejoindre quand un calme et qui se
trouve à nice bonjour quand tard vous
avez suivi le meeting de marine le pen
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire au lendemain
de ce meeting sur le fond et la forme
notamment de ce meeting est bien un
discours très offensif avec pour cible
numéro 1 bien entendu emmanuel macron
vous l'avez entendu dans l'extrait
michael il a été hué copieusement par la
salle plus d'une dizaine de fois on a
compté hier soir pendant l'heure du
discours de marine le pen la candidate a
également égrainé les noms des soutiens
des manuels macron et là encore la salle
sifflets taper du pied et c'est une
ambiance de stade a presque hier soir
une candidate qui est revenu sur les
fondamentaux du discours frontiste et
main le pen a également cherché à
arrondir les angles sur son projet
contre l'union européenne elle a parlé
d'une démarche qui avait été caricaturé
son aile rappelant qu'elle voulait une
europe coloré une europe joyeuse une
europe des nations libres je cite enfin
à michael marie le pen a adressé un
nouvel appel du pied aux électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon avec cette phrase je
dis aux français dégager les une
référence explicite aux dégagisme du
candidat de la france insoumise alors
quand un maintenant quelle est la suite
des opérations est ce que vous êtes
informations sur le programme de marine
le pen ce qu'elle va faire à
éventuellement ce week-end est bien le
grand événement c'est bien sûr le
discours de ville de villepinte du 1er
mai le deuxième est à priori le dernier
grand discours de l'entre-deux-tours de
la campagne de marine le pen un discours
du premier maître toujours emblématique
pour le front national qu'il s'agit de
bien préparer dans les prochaines 48
heures marine le pen devait
tu es un marché cette visite a été
annulée pour plutôt se concentrer sur
des interviews au qg de la campagne de
marine le pen à paris d'après d'ailleurs
l'inflation convient d'avoir du front
national merci à quentin d'avoir été
avec nous dans parlement hebdo depuis la
ville de nice
on va parler à présent du de ce scrutin
et notamment de ce quatrième homme à la
gauche de la gauche
des divergences qui éclatent au grand
jour notamment avec la position de jean
luc mélenchon qui a décidé finalement de
ne pas choisir
pierre laurent lui a pris une position
inverse on va tout seul avec astrid de
vilaine nathalie war pierre laurent et
jean-luc mélenchon ne sont toujours pas
sur la même longueur
au soir du premier tour le candidat de
la france insoumise n'a pas donné de
consigne de vote chacun chacune d'entre
vous cette en conscience quel est son
devoir
dès lors je me range le chef de file de
la france insoumise a lancé une grande
consultation auprès de ses 450 mille
partisans
pierre laurent lui prend position
immédiatement contre le front national
il appelle à voter pour emmanuel macron
nous avons toujours combattu le front
national est jamais participé à sa
banalisation notre appel à faire barrage
à marine le pen en utilisant le seul
bulletin qui lui sera malheureusement
opposés et pour nous net et sans détour
comme depuis plus d'un an pierre laurent
en appelle à l'unité de la gauche pour
les législatives
il espère construire une alliance de
benoît hamon jusqu'au parti communiste
en passant par les écologistes et la
france insoumise
mais pour le moment les discussions avec
la france insoumise sont au point mort
c'est donc l'appel que je lance
aujourd'hui notamment à la france un
soumises dont je ne comprends pas le
silence à nos appels pour une discussion
commune sur les législatives depuis
dimanche selon l'entourage de jean luc
mélenchon l'heure n'est pas encore aux
discussions d'appareils les deux hommes
devraient néanmoins se croiser
le 1er mai pour le traditionnel défilé
syndical de la fête du travail la vie
quand on regarde vos études notamment
sur jean luc mélenchon et ceux qui ont
voté pour jean luc mélenchon a
l'impression que ces personnes là
aujourd'hui ce ne veulent plus aller
voter il ya une abstention très forte
dans le camp de jean luc mélenchon oui
le phénomène majeur c'est une
progression depuis le début de la
campagne d'entre deux tours des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon sans
doute déçu comme l'a été le président de
la france en un sou mise de ça sa non
qualification de peu pour le second tour
sachant à peine un million de voix 39 %
des électeurs de jean luc mélenchon ne
désire pas n'exprime pas pour l'instant
une attention de vote alors l'absence
s'est beaucoup l'absence je donnais la
halle tout à l'heure la référence de
jacques duclos 1969 pour autant
n'oublions pas que l'électorat de jean
luc mélenchon était un électorat qui
vient du parti socialiste il a capté 26%
et l'électorat hollande 2012 de
sympathisants et de militants d'
adhérents du parti communiste quand même
le comportement le plus fréquent même
s'il est plutôt faible 45%
c'est d'aller voter contre marine le pen
et de voter emmanuel macron ya quand
même une part également marginal mais
non négligeable 16% qui seraient prêts à
voter pour marine le pen
préférant comme on lit sur les socios
madame patrie à monsieur patron on a un
électorat relativement fracturé qu'il ya
d'un côté le souvenir des luttes anti
front national le 6 mondes électorat de
gauche c'est quand même la lutte anti fn
mais qui faute de consignes précises de
jean luc mélenchon de la mission n'est
pas propriétaire de ses voix va vers une
vers un ni ni ni macron l'avez compris
cette position de la part de ses
adhérentes ses militants de ceux qui
votent alors je ne les ai pas interrogez
vous avez raison michael de distinguer
les adhérents les militants de la france
a soumis ce qu'ils sont plutôt en ligne
plutôt en adéquation à quai avec la non
prise aux positions théoriques mélenchon
sur le mode c'est essayer les électeurs
et c'est la démocratie participative
c'est le sait la consultation
qu'organise la france à celui mais du
côté des électeurs
clairement il ya sans doute un trouble
quand on le voit relativement cet
électorat fracturée même si la la pente
principal c'est aller voter contre marie
le pen comme en 2002 jean-luc mélenchon
il ya une image qui circule beaucoup
d'une image
si vous on le voit très clairement dire
voter le plus possible pour jacques
chirac même avec des gants pour faire
quantitativement baisser le score de
marine le pen si l'abstention est très
importante le score de marine le pen
quantitativement augmentera puisque
ramoin devons donc voté fait de ne pas
voter ou s'abstenir c'est clairement
faire le jeu de marine le pen
alors c'est que c'est un argument de
campagne très très fort qui est avancé
par les projets man macro et les autres
favoris c'est vrai que quantitativement
on ne peut pas le nier on va voir ce qui
se passe du côté de la droite avec la
recomposition qui est en marche
ils n'ont pas perdu de temps
quarante huit heures après l'échec de
françois fillon les sarkozystes se
retrouve dans un restaurant parisien
autour d'un petit déjeuner ils se
répartissent les rôles à jouer à laurent
wauquiez le parti un françois baroin le
combat des législatives et une place de
premier ministre en cas de cohabitation
on s'était conquis qui rassemble
aujourd'hui largement notre famille
politique c'est pour moi de loin le
meilleur candidat possible pour nous
emmener à la victoire pour les élections
l'initiative et ce sera demain un très
bon premier ministre pour la france
les fidèles de nicolas sarkozy entendent
aussi peser sur le projet porté pendant
ces législatives
ils veulent mettre en avant quelques
mesures fortes à destination des jeunes
et des classes populaires au
rétablissement des heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées non
augmentation de la tva avec équipement
revoir le plan et le projet sur
l'immigration promet la maîtrise de
l'immigration et sur le projet européen
face à cette offensive sarkozyste les
juppéiste réplique et organisent un
rassemblement le soir même aujourd'hui
on a une droite parlementaire qui est un
peu déboussolée qui a mal à ses idées
qui est encore un peu groggy par le
séisme de dimanche dernier tout seul et
ceux qui voudront s'isoler qui voudront
faire une politique seul en pensant
qu'ils pourront avoir raison tout seul
auront tort
alain juppé vient en personne soutenir
ses troupes et défendre une consigne de
vote claire pour le second tour
quand je vois certains rangs des
positions incongrues pourtant noté
l'opep vont pas s'abstenir mekouar
les escrocs de la logique après ce débat
sur la consigne de vote
un autre s'ouvre chez les républicains
faudra-t-il ou pas travailler avec
emmanuel macron s'il est élu président
nous accueillons à présent sur ce
plateau céline martel bonjour céline
vous suivez la droite et on vient de
voir le reportage que vous avez fait il
y à bien désormais deux camps séparés
entre ceux qui appellent à voter
macron emmanuel macron et les autres oui
katia et dès dimanche cette ligne de
fracture est apparu on a d'un côté la
majorité des républicains beaucoup de
jupes et east quelques sarkozyste qui
appellent à voter clairement pour
emmanuel macron ans pour eux c'est le
front républicain qu'il faut défendre à
tout prix et d'autres minoritaires d'une
ligne plus droitière notamment eric
ciotti georges fenech e laurent wauquiez
pour eux il ne pour eux c'est un mauvais
une mauvaise stratégie que d'appeler
clairement à voter pour emmanuel macron
pour eux ce serait compliqué d'expliquer
aux militants qu'il faut voter pour
emmanuel macron pour le lendemain leur
expliquer d'aller voter contre les
députés en marche aux législatives pour
eux c'est une stratégie qui est
incohérente
alors ces deux blocs qui se sont
affrontés toute la semaine lundi au
bureau politique
on l'a vu c'était des heures de
discussions pour arriver seulement un
communiqué un communiqué qui n'a même
pas fait l'objet d'un vote
c'est bernard accoyer qui l'a dit voter
ça aurait été exposé nos divisions et
même les sarkozystes qu'on a vu à se
réunir dans le reportage emploi un petit
déjeuner même les sarkozystes se
déchirent entre eux un député présent à
ce petit-déjeuner m'a raconté une
altercation très vive entre luc chatel
et georges fenech qui ont failli en
venir aux mains
georges fenech considère que toute une
attitude complètement suicidaire
il a accusé luc chatel de de mener à la
fin de son parti politique
quand luc chatel a dit mais moi j'ai
défendu françois fillon jusqu'au bout si
vous aviez fait comme moi on n'en serait
pas là aujourd'hui
vous voyez un petit peu les propos qui
sont échangées en ce moment j'en sais
rien
alors que c'est quoi le prochain
objectif essayer de sauver des
législatives c'est sauver les députés
oui voilà en fait les républicains
sincères les rangs en ce moment pour cet
objectif des législatives qui arrive
très prochainement
ils ont réussi à trouver un consensus et
c'est le nous
c'est le non pardon de françois baroin
évidemment je françois baroin c'est lui
qui est un peu un positionnement assez
central dans le parti qui pourraient
tous les mettre d'accord c'est celui qui
devait être le premier ministre de
nicolas sarkozy
puis le premier ministre de françois
fillon maintenant les sarkozystes
l'imaginent déjà premier ministre dans
un dans un gouvernement de cohabitation
avec baby si on regarde un petit peu
l'électorat de la droite électorat qui a
voté françois fillon ils se reportent
majoritairement aujourd'hui sur qui sur
emmanuel macron oui mais de manière
relative 1 43 % seulement des électeurs
de droite voterait emmanuel macron 31%
serait sur un ni ni abstention ou blancs
et nuls et 24 % chez marine le pen c'est
très intéressant ce qui vient d'être dit
d'une part on voit très bien que ces
droites année zéro le parti est
complètement groggy par cette élection
qui était jugé rappelez vous au soir du
second tour de la primaire imperdable la
motivation majeure des électeurs de la
primaire de droite que l'ifop a
interrogé
c'était je vais élire le prochain
président de la république on a une
droite fracturée 43% problèmes
pourraient même macron c'est peu mais
pendant toute la campagne il a été
stigmatisée comme le continuateur du
quinquennat emmanuel hollande un car
pour le front national c'est cette
droite en fusion notamment dans des
territoires du sud est de la france avec
les idées du front national
et puis il ya un vrai pari est ce qu'on
peut imaginer qu'une droite qui a connu
cette défaite historique puis se
rattraper aux élections et créative
c'est lé sport en 1991 souvient comme de
la manière dont ça s'est terminé de
manière catastrophique
justement ces lignes une petite question
par rapport à ceux ce prochain objectif
fort à droite essayait de sauver le
maximum de sièges pour les législatives
est-ce que quels sont les atouts des
députés députés aient l'air finalement
l'implantation peut-être oui tout à fait
alors les républicains espèrent encore
remporter ces législatives c'est ce
qu'il nous répète parce qu'ils pensent
qu'ils ont beaucoup de candidats bien
implanté le socle minimum vraiment le
minimum de députés qu'il pourrait
remporter ces 120 et alors ils mettent
en avant donc l'implantation des députés
face à ce qu'ils appellent les candidats
internet d'emmanuel macro oui alors il
une vraie nuances sur ce qui vient
d'être dit de leurs parce que ce que
vous allez y et je remets pas en cause
vos propos quand on regarde qui est
arrivé en tête dans les circonscriptions
métropolitaines dans 260 c conscription
c'est emmanuel macron bien sûr le pari
c'est comment passer du vote macron
incarné à des candidats sans doute peu
connu et ayant peu d'expérience
politique
à part bien sûr des ralliements que par
définition ne connaît pas aujourd'hui
donne 216 216 ces contributions marine
le pen arrive en tête et même une
vingtaine où elle dépasse 35 % croient
que françois fillon s'est à peine 75 %
75 par dont 75 circonscriptions
on a du mal compte tenu de cette défaite
historique d'imaginer devant fins de
voir comment la droite pourrait se
rattraper aux élections législatives
bien sûr ça sera une nouvelle élection
mais n'oublions pas qu'avec l'inversion
du calendrier électoral depuis
maintenant 2002 l'élection législative
est très fortement indexé amplifiée par
le rapport de forces issu de l'élection
présidentielle ce qu'on voulait faire et
convaincu majorité aujourd'hui au
président de la république issu déjà ça
a été la règle je dis presque
automatique en 2002 2007 2012 aura bien
sûr c'est très différent avec un âne
emmanuel macron s'il l'emportait le 7
mai qui doit avoir une quinzaine vat m
une vingtaine de députés pour lui passer
d'une quinzaine de députés à 280 c'est
une vraie marche d'un autre d'un autre
côté n'oublions pas que le
l'enseignement majeur du premier tour
d'élection présidentielle c'est
l'effondrement du parti socialiste
benoît hamon on arrive en tête dans
aucune circonscription est une vraie
difficulté une vraie défaite pour la
droite souci merci céline pour votre âme
à vis de vos commentaires on va donc
parler de ce qui se passe à gauche au
parti socialiste notamment après le
score de benoît hamon cette gauche
complètement décomposer aujourd'hui on
va cela avec elsa monaghan à 6,3 pour
cent le score le plus bas pour le parti
socialiste depuis 1969 un échec cuisant
cinq ans après l'élection de françois
hollande
pour benoît hamon c'est la défaite du
parti
cet échec est une profonde meurtrissures
je mesure la sanction historique 1 les
it in que vous avez exprimée envers le
parti socialiste alors le ps est il
menacé d'implosion pour l'heure pas de
règlements de compte le moment est grave
on remet les sujets qui fâchent à plus
tard
l'introspection viendra l'analyse de
cette défaite prendra du temps car elle
vient de loin mais pas maintenant car le
temps de l'explication n'est pas venu
aujourd'hui il faut se situer dans le
temps de l'action pourtant au ps il y à
bien une fracture entre ceux qui
entendent représentait l'opposition à
emmanuel macron s'il est élu et ceux qui
veulent participer d'une manière ou
d'une autre à une majorité
gouvernementale
ces derniers manuel valls en tête sont
très critiques à l'égard de benoît hamon
quand on mène au fond une campagne d'
extrême gauche ou de gauche de la gauche
ou récolte ou simplement les fruits de
cette campagne c'est à dire en
abandonnant ce qui a toujours été la
position d'un candidat socialiste c'est
à dire une position centrale au coeur de
la société
les autres veulent se tourner vers les
verts et jean-luc mélenchon ombre et
appellent de leurs voeux une alliance
rose rouge verte
nous irons devant les électeurs c'est
vrai avec un projet en projet de gauche
j'espère un projet qui sera capable de
rassembler toutes les gauches pas
seulement les socialistes mais toutes
les gauches l'enjeu des discussions
qu'il faudra voir maintenant si le ps
souhaite repousser l'exercice
d'autocritique il faut bientôt trancher
la question des investitures pour les
élections législatives
si ceux qui ont parrainé emmanuel macron
été exclu ce qu'ils ont simplement
soutenu sont pour l'heure toujours
investi leur car a été transmis à la
commission nationale des conflits
aucune date n'a été fixée pour l'instant
c'est pas encore le grand soir de la
gauche il va falloir faire un petit peu
le tout le ménage en tout cas de ce qui
a été fait l'inventaire de ce qui a été
fait mais quand même les maquis 10 comme
manuel valls et n'a pas été assez
central doute qu'ils disent au contraire
et n'a pas été assez à gauche c'est
l'explosion coup pour l'euro en train de
voir sur le jeu oui c'est un score
historiquement bas pour parti socialiste
vient clairement des arts de campagne de
benoît hamon et puis une difficulté de
positionnement il a été pris en étau
entre jean luc mélenchon
dans la dynamique s'est clairement
fondée sur le siphonnage des voix de
benoît hamon mails et mma kron benoît
hamon paraissait trop socialiste pour
beaucoup d'électeurs de gauche déçus du
quinquennat de françois hollande et
quand voter pour jean luc mélenchon il
apparaissait aussi trop frondeurs trop
dans la critique et dans la non comment
dire la difficulté à à défendre et
assumer le bilan de françois hollande et
ses électeurs la socialiste sont allés
massivement chez emmanuel macron dans le
sondage jour du vote de l'ifop et dans
le rolling on voyait très bien qu'un
électeur d'hollande sur deux aller
directement chez émane macron benoît
hamon n'en a pris que 16%
maintenant c'est également ps année zéro
il est le principal groupe à l'assemblée
nationale sans doute quand on projette
le résultat des élections
présidentielles sur les circonscriptions
législatives
le ps ne se maintiendrait nulle part au
second tour c'est bien sûr ceux qui ne
se passera pas mais on voit très bien la
difficulté encore plus grande que celle
de la droite dont on a parlé
précédemment pour le parti socialiste
dans un contexte sans doute comme lors
des élections précédentes et là on en
véritable continuité dans un contexte
d'émiettement d'éparpillement
extraordinaire des forces de gauche
alors chez une dernière question
peut-être sur les notions de front
républicain est ce que pour vous le
front républicain veut encore dire
quelque chose
oui dans l'âme dans dans la mesure où il
a fortement marché aux élections
régionales en paca face à marion
maréchal-le pen dans les outrances face
à face à marine vannes mais le front
républicain
outre le soutien très fort du parti
socialiste et des électeurs de gauche à
christian estrosi et à xavier bertrand
s'est fondé sur une sur participations
une sur mobilisation électorale qui a
noyé si je puis dire
la dynamique frontiste de premier tour
là ce qui est très différent et
présidentielle on l'a vu ensemble
précédemment c'est que l'abstention a
l'air extrêmement août
en tout cas il ya toutes les chances de
crétins et qu'elle soit la craie du
scrutin et qu'elles soient peut-être et
même sûrement quand on regarde notre
rowling supérieur à ce que est ce
qu'elle a été le 23 avril dernier c'est
ça la clé du scrutin
merci beaucoup frédéric dabi d'avoir été
à l'invité de parlements et 12 spéciales
évidemment sur l'entre-deux tours de
fait campagne présidentielle à très
bientôt sa chaîne parlementaire
[Musique]
vous rendez vous avec public sénat
je souhaite devenir votre président le
président des patriotes
je lance un appel à tous les patriotes
sincères d'où qu'ils viennent
deux projets radicalement différents
mais des mots en miroir
tel est le paradoxe de ce duel de second
tour antisystème patriote comment les
finalistes décline t-il
les tam qui leur ont permis de se hisser
au second tour
et comment réagit style aux critiques et
aux attaques cette semaine des as billon
en tout bien tout honneur la candidate
du peuple et celui du travail
déshabillons l'est demain 15h sur public
sénat